[Musique]
c'est mon boxeur que j'ai acheté en
adaptant 55000 veille au soir avec
l'argent la forme et murray ça fait
moche or je lave toutes les semaines
quand lise boucher est allé travailler à
fort mcmurray en 2006 elle avait parfois
l'impression que l'argent tombé du ciel
je travaillais comme femme de chambre
est donc comme ça et me 5500 par mois
c'était vraiment bien payés jeu très
bonne heureuse d'avoir ce salaire
c'était l'époque du boom pétrolier des
dizaines de travailleurs à fouiller
chaque semaine à former cnri laurent la
job alors pour profiter peut aussi la
ruée vers l'or noir même les feuilles du
tim hortons langevin ps de l'eure à ce
moment alors je veux dire souvent les
gens autour de toi aussi qu'ils
dépensent sans compter aussi on va chez
walmart les tablettes est tout le temps
avec johanne gonthier et le monde
l'achète à chaque fois un gilet et
d'acheteurs toutes les couleurs moi j'ai
vu du monde avec des bots camionneurs
ski-doo 4 ou tout ce que vous pouvez
penser les gones la bête mais en 2014
le prix du baril de pétrole a chuté les
beaux jours était terminée lise qui a
perdu son emploi est finalement rentré
au québec
heureusement elle avait de l'argent de
côté contrairement à d'autres
travailleurs car il y avait la chute de
l'huile il ya beaucoup de véhicules qui
ont été abandonnés des maisons qui ont
été abandonnés les meubles dedans des
gens sont partis avec le linge les
enfants un peu chien mais c'était
vraiment triste de voir ça
la tristesse c'est aussi ce que
ressentent jean marc guillemot se
promenant dans le centre ville de fort
mcmurray aujourd'hui clichy c'est notre
restaurant qui était attaché à l'hôtel
donc le locateur ne pouvons plus payer
ses demandes financières a fallu clic
itx et tout embarqué avec lui le
gestionnaire fait tout ce qu'il peut
pour garder ses huit hôtels à flot nous
avons maintenant une occupation de 40 %
40 % alors que dans le bourg durant le
boom c'était combien il y avait des
hôtels qui faisait 93% à l'année
d'ailleurs quand une équipe de radio
canada l'avait rencontré en 2012
jean-marc ne pouvait imaginer la fin des
beaux jours c'est très bien qu'un prêt
de sens deux cents ans de pétrole
est-ce qu'ils ont été aveuglés par ce
boom
absolument on est toujours réactif on
n'a pas été proactif il n'y a pas que
des résidents de fort mcmurray qui ont
cru que la manne pétrolière allait durer
pendant plusieurs décennies encore le
gouvernement albertain aussi la crue
selon plusieurs experts
il a même manqué de vision politique à
long terme l'albertain a très mal géré
ses revenus pétroliers au fil des années
puisque tous les revenus étaient
essentiellement utilisés pour payer les
dépenses courantes du gouvernement
2006 le gouvernement draft klein a même
envoyé des chèques de 400 dollars tous
les albertains en servant des surplus
pétroliers
on est loin de la réalité norvégienne de
pays d'europe du nord qui est aussi
producteur de pétrole a investi depuis
plus de vingt ans presque toutes ces
redevances dans un fonds souverain
c'est un énorme bas de laine pour les
générations futures qui vont aujourd'hui
1400 milliards de dollars l'alberta
aussi avait créé un fonds similaire dans
les années 70 avant noir qui était
ministre progressiste conservateur à
l'époque avait contribué à le mettre en
oeuvre
mais dès 1987 la province à ses cibles
des classes et de l'argent sauf pour
trois milliards de dollars dans les
années 2000
le gouvernement albertain a même puiser
dans le fonds pour financer d'autres
projets comme des terrains de golf
en bas les mesures aujourd'hui la
norvège a accumulé avec son fonds plus
de 260 mille dollars par habitant alors
qu'en alberta sonique 4200 dollars par
personne 1 à 3%
ford est mort et on sent plus indulgents
s'en va avec décideurs albertain gens
comme vous voyez j'ai cherché le nouvel
hôpital
depuis 40 ans la population de la
province a augmenté trois fois plus vite
que celles de la norvège
il a donc fallu construire une foule
d'hôpitaux d'écoles de routes mais ils
ont maintenant après ça ils ont vidé les
tiroirs
parce qu'on avait besoin justement du
tout d'infrastructures acheteurs pour se
préparer mais est-ce que vous pensez que
les beaux jours de fort mcmurray le boum
ça va revenir en selon vous le boom
comme c'était avant probablement jamais
mais on va pas comme la charité on peut
pas s'arrêter
même si la croissance reprend d'une
manière plus modeste
les bouchers espère que les albertains
seront plus prudents à l'avenir
prévoyez que ces choses là c est ça
commence verte mais des fois ça arrête
versée
[Musique]